رغم ان ازمه لبنان لم تطوى صفحتها بعد الا
ان بيروت تبدو وكانها السعاده ترونق
اعيادها بخلاف الاعوام الماضيه
وسط المدينه هنا كان اشبه بمدن الاشباح
ليلا لكن الزينه تعادت لتضيء لياليه
من الزوار
اما القرى الميلاد واصواته فعادت لتنتشر
في اكثر من منطقه وان كانت بمبادرات خاصه
[موسيقى]
ايه ده مش نحن راح نقوم بحالنا ما حدا راح
يساعدنا فمثل ما كنا عم نقول قبل انه
القطاع الخاص هو يلي امل هالبلاد مزبوط ما
في غير قطاع الخاص هو راح يرجع يقوم
هالبلاد
السفر والسياحه
وطبعا من شركه طيران فوق 600,000 راح يجي
على لبنان هذا الموسم هذا الشهرين لا
تاريخ اليوم صار واصل تقريبا 270,000 طبعا
احنا بنقول لك كل اللبنانيين ولكل سوريا
موسم جديد من المواسم السياحيه يعمل خلاله
اللبنانيون خيرا مع رفع عدد رحلات الطيران
اعلنت وزاره السياحه ان ايرادات الموسم
الصيفي لعام 2022 تجاوزت السته مليار
دولار لكن هذا الرقم لم يؤدي الى تحسين
عجله الاقتصاد خاصه ان المستفيدين فضلوا
ابقاء هذه الاموال داخل المنازل
يؤكد كارلوس صاحبه احد المطاعم النعامه
2022 كان الافضل منذ بدء الازمه لكنه
حفاوه المواسم السياحيه لم تلغي ازمه
الثقه فيرفض كارلوس كغيره من اللبنانيين
اذاعه ما يتبقى من ارباح داخل المصرف
وعن هذا لانه يعني الازمه فواتتنا بمشكل
كثير كبير ومشغوله تقبض الاكتريه كشته
تقدر انت بالنهايه
انت مشغوله بتتعمل بالناده
الازمه لكنه هذه الاموال تحفظوا في
المنازل يستمتع اللبنانيون باعيادهم بعيدا
عن المصارف
اغنيه تيم العربيه بيروت